boulevard hetelou ou encore le quartier
situé derrière la cathédrale ici on
parle de prostitution visible difficile
de déterminer un chiffre exact une
trentaine voire une quarantaine de
personnes seraient sur le bord du
trottoir certaines depuis des dizaines
d'années mais à tour comme dans de
nombreuses villes la prostitution a un
nouveau visage le coupable internet
c'est par le biais de site d'escort girl
que les clients accèdent à une véritable
banque de données la prostitution d
cachée est très insécurisante beaucoup
la refusent et il y en a même beaucoup
c'est cell qui sont dans une dans une
dans une prostitution visible qui vous
disent qu'elles se sentent plus en
sécurité sur le bord du trottoir elles
sont plus intégrées sur le bord du
trottoir que chez elle après un
rendez-vous pris sur Internet ne sachant
pas du tout qui quand comment et qui va
venir surtout oui rien qu'à tour des
dizaines d'annonçants ligne certaines
jeunes femmes et jeunes hommes viennent
de Paris ou de la région parisienne pour
s'installer quelques jours à tour et
offrir leurs services depuis 40 ans le
mouvement d'unit accompagne les
personnes prostituées dans leur démarche
d'accès aux soins ou encore à la justice
mais c'est aussi et surtout un lieu
d'écoute si depuis toujours ici on a
parlé de sexe et d'argent aujourd'hui la
prostitution se transforme on parle de
troc du corps cette femme qui qui était
obligée de enfin qui éta obligée qui en
sur quoi avec ces deux filles qu'elle
est levé seu et le voisin qui lui
proposait d'aller faire ses courses
toutes les semaines contre un petit
service sexuel dans l'après-midi comment
elle vit ça quoi et puis partager avec
elle comment elle vit ça partager ses
souffrances voilà ce qu'a fait Véronique
à travers l'écriture il y a 14 ans elle
coupe avec le milieu de la prostitution
un milieu qui lui a volé 5 ans de sa vie
si demain on pénalise les clients ça
voudra dire tout de suite il faut
vraiment que ces femmes on puisse les
sortir de cette précarité tout de suite
parce que c'est pas mettre un petit
pansement et puis repousser le problème
et les laisser dans la misère c'est
aujourd'hui elle travaille elle mange
demain si elle mange plus il faut tout
de suite leur donner du travail ne plus
jamais les laisser dans la misère cette
femme enfin Véronique nous donne son
chiffre selon elle 80 personnes se
prostitueraient à tour